[Music]
we reaffirmed our mutual clear and
strong commitment to Albania's European
Union integration process we commanded
the Albanian authorities and the society
more broadly for the achievements in the
past year particularly all the
determined work that the country is
undertaking on its unprecedented and
very much appreciated judicial reform I
firmly believe that the increased
engagement in 2018 between the Western
Balkans and the European Union done for
example through the Western Balkan
strategy as well as the Sofia summit is
on our shared interest we of the
European Union side remain determined to
accompany Albania for a very successful
2019 we are more than determined to
continue on this path
Phuc leadership RIA
Lynn's own Chand Reema the quality can
decide the Ashna ancient Persian regime
in European Lucas new process mechanic
urged me process it silly Barone Syria
strategy to Sri Lanka birch and moment
insertion Dharma regime in communist
portion he did voluntary became a
Terrapin even top coat receiver Brandon
de cantar hurry confirm om Shakti Takumi
vendors were in town pert viewer make
trend Albania made progress and has
clearly foreign potentials also in the
field of economic governance market
accompanied economy is progressing we
positively noted the continuation of the
economic and employment curves over the
last year and the current federal
economic environment provides an
opportunity to accelerate the
implementation of economic reforms new
accession is a shared objective which
will be matched by concrete actions cost
party dialogue is therefore essential
for this